this is the Joo unraveling podcast
episode number 38 with Daryl Cooper and
me Joo willink and yes it's been a while
since we've done one of
these but the name of the podcast is the
unraveling podcast and it certainly
seems at this time that things are
unraveling very quickly it is October
11th
and well things are falling apart very
quickly over in the Middle East in
Israel in
Gaza quote from Blood
Meridian makes no difference what men
think of War said the judge War
[Music]
endures War always was here before man
was war waited for him the ultimate
trade awaiting its ultimate
practitioner that is the way it was and
will be that
way and not some other way and sometimes
I got to just refer to that book to
remind me that human beings are savages
and we will
just kill each other as well ask man
what he thinks of
stone
exactly uh yeah so sometimes you know
you get you you know for me I'm an
optimistic person I guess I might say
and I'll look at the world and things
seem to be moving in the right
directions and things are going seem to
be going well and then you see what's
happened in the past week or so just
remind reminds me that
yeah you can be heading in the right
direction and get completely and utterly
derailed by the Mayhem that's going on
and you know I I always talk about war
being a test of wills and it definitely
is a test of wills and the only reason
War happens is because we don't know
whose will is stronger cuz if we knew
whose will was Stronger we wouldn't
fight you know if if if I knew that you
had a stronger will in your country than
I had in mine I'd go uh you know what we
better just figure out a deal here and
vice versa but when you think your will
is stronger than mine and I think my
will is stronger than yours there's only
one way to find out it's the same thing
in a in a bar fight right it's like no
one picks a fight that they know they're
going to lose or very few people do
sometimes they still do CU you get
emotional and you get w I mean you could
say that about you could say that
about um Hamas right now do they think
they're going to win territory
back no their Victory conditions are
very different yeah they're they know
that them getting people killed is good
I mean otherwise you wouldn't go in and
execute the operation that they executed
with clearly you know I was listening to
somebody debrief on the operation that
they conducted they talked about the
coordination this Mass coordination how
it had to have been coordinated at such
a high level that that has to be Iranian
influence and look I'm yeah there's
Iranian influence but when you have
decentralized command and you just give
the commander intent that at this time
go in and your mission is to murder rape
kill kidnap and you just unleash
everyone at a given time that's actually
a squared away method for creating a lot
of Chaos in a very short period of time
rather than trying to coordinate like
the US military would coordinate
combined arms and they'd have phase
lines CU we you know they don't care
about collateral damage number one they
don't care about Blue on Blue at all so
they don't care about any of the things
that we con that constrain like a
western Force like America there's all
these constraints that we have on us
Rules of Engagement collateral damage
Blue on Blue those types of things so we
set up these very control
ring uh timelines and phase lines they
didn't have to do any of that they say
hey look at this time go rape kill
murder kidnap get capture people if you
can and that's so you tell a bunch of
Fanatics to do that yep guess what was
there some limited coordination between
hey we're going to take the motorcycles
you guys cut the wire we'll put the
explosives on yeah there was some groups
that were clearly working together some
of those air assaults on the whatever
paragliders sure there's some
coordination there we're all going to
take off at the same time we're all
going to fly to this General region
but it's it's chaotic in nature but it
takes a lot less coordination because
they don't they don't care about
anything they don't have any rules they
don't have any constraints it definitely
demonstrated a level a capability that
Hamas has never shown before um you know
the paraglider thing interestingly they
were they had those available in 2014
during that war they didn't put them to
use but I just just read this morning
actually that they were using those
things a couple times from Lebanon back
in the 70s so that's an old uh tactic I
guess but I do think that you know like
I used to go to Israel a lot for work um
I would work with their with IDF
personnel and contractors over there on
air defense matters and like uh over
drinks I talk to these guys and you know
I would always want to just learn from
them their opinions on things in the
region stuff I I would do that wherever
I went and what I found consistently I I
started going over there in about in
2009 I probably went there at least a
dozen maybe 15 or 20 times um from 2009
to about 2019 and so this is three years
after when I started going over there
three years after the 2006 war against
Hezbollah and um you know the Israelis
they had a tough time on the ground they
ended up pulling back and just sort of
leveling Southern Lebanon and it was a
real wakeup call um that you know the
Arab states Iran that these were not the
only military threats that they had to
worry about they had this this group
Hezbollah up here that had to be taken
seriously and so by the time I got up
there and started talking to them all
any of them I mean they would talk about
the Iranian nuclear program and things
like that sometimes but it was like a
distant threat sort of the thing they
were concerned with on a day-to-day
basis was Hezbollah like they had a lot
of respect for hezbollah's capabilities
on the ground um their their their
willingness to to die in place and and
actually coordinate their their
movements and they were getting better
and better equipped and everybody I
talked to looked down the road and they
they just assumed it was 100% guaranteed
as far as they were concerned there was
going to be another war with Hezbollah
and then that the next one was going to
be decisive one way or the other and
everybody expected it and that's what
they were planning for now on the other
hand what I found was that Hamas was
very much underestimated in in a lot of
ways I I I shouldn't say underestimated
in the first half so the first five
years like 2009 to 2014 that I went
there 2009 they had that brief conflict
the flare up there um and Hamas did what
they always do they were terrible they
they showed no ability to coordinate uh
no ability to to layer their attacks
just they would scatter and flee
whenever any serious IDF uh forces came
came within range and just had no
cohesion whatsoever no unit support
and they were looked at as I wouldn't
say quite like a police problem but like
a problem not a strategic problem they
were looked at as people who like they
could come over and pick out some soft
targets and do some real horrific damage
like to people and and to property but
that is not going to damage Israel's
position strategically or anything like
that and 2014 came and something
happened that that we're not seeing
right now from Israel which I'm
gratified about uh you know three
Israeli teenagers were kidnapped and
murdered by some guys who were
affiliated with
Hamas and the Israelis just sort of flew
off the handle and sent a bunch of
ground forces into Gaza and Hamas was
waiting for him and they had learned a
lot from hezbollah's solid performance
against the IDF in 2006 you know they
grabbed the IDF by the belt got real
close and sort of shut down their air
and artillery uh advantages and you know
took 10 to1 casualties still but they
but they did inflict casualties they
destroyed you know a lot of armored
vehicles tanks uh a couple tanks and
inflicted Israeli uh um Personnel
casualties and it got to the point where
the Israeli you know I mean they had
huge Network tunnel system tunnels that
could not be easily destroyed without
Israeli Engineers like actually going
and and setting explosives they they
were very well like reinforced concrete
you know bunkers and tunnel systems
booby trapped IED networks just all over
the place and they were also
demonstrating combat capabilities that
Hamas had never demonstrated before they
were effectively using snipers they they
had you know 25 to 3500 man brigades six
of them distributed along the front each
responsible for a different sector that
we're working together it seems from uh
to a certain extent each one of of them
had its own layout of capabilities it
had infantry anti-tank forces mortar
forces and they were able to coordinate
work together and provide like
supporting fire with rockets and and
more this is just something that Hamas
had never shown before and it showed
that they are a military problem now
that Israel had to take seriously but
even after that
War uh the people that I talked to and
you see the same kind of thing analysts
in the media and stuff would sort of
look at it the same way that yeah if we
ever go push in to Gaza again like we've
got to be prepared for them to put up a
a resistance that we have to take
seriously but nobody took seriously
hamas's the possibility that Hamas had a
strong offensive capability that they
could do something like this I mean I
remember the morning a few hours into
the
attack there were reports already that
there were there was fighting going on
in 22 different locations that they had
come ground you know uh bulldo the fence
and cut wires and then rushed through in
Vans and trucks and motorcycles they had
those paragliders they had people coming
up the coast and they all hit their
attack spaces in within a window of a
couple hours that's that's impressive
yep and that's just not something that
Israel had ever anticipated from them
and I I suppose that's not a mistake
they're going to make again and so
they're not rushing in with their Ground
Forces right now they are preparing it
looks like a large ground Invasion uh
what the goal of that is going to be and
what Israel's Victory conditions here
are very hard to kind of
foresee um but you know they haven't
rushed in on the ground yet and so it
tells me that they have learned at least
that lesson from 2014 and it's going to
be it there's going to be some fighting
though especially if you know Hamas
bragged a lot in 2014 that they had a
lot of man pads and uh anti-air machine
gun like heavy machine guns and stuff
and they never used them or if they did
they didn't use them effectively and
down in the Israeli aircraft in 2014 but
if they do have even a capability that
Israel has to account for that might
constrain their air operations so that
they do have to go in in this incredibly
densely packed place I mean it's you
know like the most crowded areas of Hong
Kong like level of of population density
and fight amidst ruined buildings with
booby traps and IEDs everywhere and PE
and civilians everywhere uh it's going
to be very difficult it's going to be
very difficult yeah that the you know
I've been looking at some of the
pictures of the way Gaza looks even
right now it's a it's a nightmare it's
all bombed out and you and I were
talking before we pressed record you
know when you bomb a building and you
think to yourself well okay that that's
no longer a threat that's not true and
there it's it's still a threat
especially when you have all these
tunnel systems because all the air power
in the world against a fortified
underground bunker like they're still
there and and it doesn't take much
common sense to go oh we're about to get
bombed you go in the shelter you wait
there for a few hours and when the
booming stops you come back out and you
get ready to fight and they set up all
kinds of you know when when you when you
drop these buildings these reveled out
buildings actually form really good
fighting positions so it's going to be
really hard and when you go in there
like you're talking about air support
again yeah if they if they have man pads
how how many helicopters they going to
sacrifice are the some of the images
that are coming through right now of of
Israeli helicopters getting shot down
are any of those confirmed are those
real I only saw two and they were both
video game footage so so we're
in the era of ghost of Kev so it's
really hard yeah it's hard to know um
but if they start losing some
helicopters the fast movers overhead you
know that that becomes a tough job when
you're trying to drop bombs and Close
Quarters with civilians and friendlies
that are moving through the area so
really I think this boils down to more
ground fighting with tanks and with
infantry on the ground which
is hey if you do absolutely everything
right you're still taking significant
casualties and even if Hamas was not
purposely using those people as human
Shields the environment would guarantee
massive civilian casualties there's
going to be massive civilian casualties
there's going going to be massive
Israeli casualties I mean it's just
going to be it's just going to be a
blood bath it's going to be a blood bath
on both sides and you know the the
perception from the world is of course
the dying civilians is going to going to
create a lot of animosity against Israel
and people may or may not remember what
triggered that I people saying oh this
time's different like you know people
are going to remember because of the
scale of this atrocity and I don't think
so like that's just not how it's ever
worked in the past for Israel you know
you look at 2014 these three boys were
kidnapped tortured mutilated and
murdered these they're children and at
first everybody was vigils you know for
these three boys even up in the West
Bank the Palestinians like uh civilians
they were holding vigils up there even
and around the world the consensus was
that Israel has to do something they
can't just let something like this pass
but it only took a few weeks you know
after their ground assault got got
stalled they pulled back and just sort
of you know they they they just
bombarded the hell out of the whole area
and really destroy like large sections
of Gaza I mean I think uh the estimates
are that about
2500 people were killed and about 10,000
were wounded in Gaza and 60 to 70% of
those are civilians not exactly easy to
say what that means you know if there's
a 16-year-old boy that does chores for
Hamas and maybe even sometimes totes a
rifle but he's not like he doesn't have
a card in his wallet is he a civilian so
that's kind of hard but um you know
that's kind of what happened in 2006 and
Lebanon too is they got stalled by
Hezbollah on the ground they pulled back
and just bombarded the hell out of
Southern Lebanon both of those cases it
took a week or two before World opinion
especially in Europe which you know it's
a little bit a little bit stronger for
Israel over here uh because of well
various reasons the Evangelical
Christian Community and just our
relationship to them but up in Europe
where they have a sort of history of
like more leftwing anti-colonial furor
you or more of an anti-colonial Focus um
among their left wi than we do over here
and now today obviously there's the you
know the issue of like all these
European countries Western European
countries have large Muslim populations
that you would like to say uh you know
are out there condemning Hamas for
massacring civilians and kidnapping
women and children but and some of them
are absolutely you know but not uh not
all of them and not enough of them and
that's something
that you hate to say it but these are
democratic countries where people have
to get elected by uh you know by by
voters and that that population in
Europe is going to affect European
politics and how they address situations
like this so I I I have kind of a
question to get back to the combat
situation where you know I was thinking
um as I was driving over
here about how you know you look at in
2004 when we went into fuia and the
Marines were just sort of you know was
followed an atrocity you know against
those Blackwater guys and videos of them
being paraded around and stuff and so we
reacted and Bush sent the Marines in
there and told them to go take care of
the situation and when you tell Marines
to do that they're going to do it and
fua was destroyed I mean that City got
wrecked a little later on
just to point out they gave the civilian
populace ample time to get out of fuia
that was that was probably about as that
was about as good as you could do it
yeah about as clean as you could do it
they gave this and the and the mujahadin
didn't really keep them there so there
was a mass Exodus leaving fujia before
before the Marines went in and took it
so then 2006 we want to go into
radi the Iraqi government doesn't want
another fujia and so you guys go go in
and take a totally different Tack and
the question I was thinking about is you
know in radi you had some Iraqi but a
lot of international jihadists and
others who had come in and they were
extorting and blackmailing and
threatening and raping and killing the
people of radi who you know if you could
convince not that they I'm sure they had
their supporters or their you know
collaborators but you could go in there
with the hope and expectation that um if
you could demonstrate to the population
that you could protect them from these
people that there would be people
willing to help you because they were
suffering under this occupation
essentially of these jihadists y um how
how is something like that even possible
in a place where the civilian population
I mean it's not like every single person
is a member of Hamas but if it comes
between the Israelis and Hamas then they
are supporters of Hamas like there not
there there's no turn you know Israel's
always been able to like turn one guy
here who wanted some money and
infiltrate over there but like in terms
of a campaign of winning the population
over that's not going to happen does not
seem possible at all yeah uh you know
and and also in Rada you had the people
that were kind of bringing the
population on board eventually was the
tribal shakes that Liv there that wanted
that didn't want Al-Qaeda there so you
had a actually a totally different
scenario yeah so is there I've had a
couple people hit me up like oh are they
going to do this like ratti and I said
no they're not going to do this like
ratti this is going to be not like ratti
and it's not going to be like fuia
either because there's going to be
civilians in there and they're like like
you already pointed out a lot of
civilians are going to die and that's
what's about to happen um you know could
they do some kind of Siege Warfare where
they've shut off the water they've shut
off the power they've shut off the the
the you know they prevent food from
getting in there and they start to say
look you know we'll we'll give food to
civilians that come out and want to
surrender and want to want to you know
leave the area come on out um would
Hamas allow them to do that no I don't
think so yeah and you know that that
also runs into the problem that if past
engagements are a guide that time is not
on the side of the Israelis like the
clock is ticking right now
where they have like they have room to
get something
done before the critical mass of world
opinion says enough is enough because
it's just how you know we don't live
there these aren't our brothers and
sisters who are getting massacred you
know in in in some kibuts in southern
Israel and so people just see Mass death
and destruction in Gaza and it doesn't
it's not like it turns them into Hamas
supporters but it makes the global
Community say you know okay enough is
enough like stop stop stop let's you
know broker a ceasefire or something and
once that you know to a certain extent
after something like this Israel is
going to be like we were after 911 like
yeah piss off if you don't like it like
we have we're going to go deal with this
and we're tired of listening to you
people
but you know Israel is a state with
long-term interests and they can't just
totally do that you know I mean after
911 that mentality was was strong and it
lasted a pretty good amount of time
I mean this was this wasn't even a
matter of days and there was supporting
uh Palestinian support protests all over
the world so this timeline that the
Israelis have is I think it's already
actually gone so now what they're
working on is how do we move forward
period And I I don't think I don't think
they at this
point care I don't think it you know if
you what's the what's the the percentage
of population of Americans that were
killed on September 11th you know we
have 330 million people here we lost
3,000 there's 10 million people in in
Israel that's one of the things my
Israeli friends always bring up is they
say you know this is a really small
country pretty much everybody you talk
to over there at least knows somebody
who knows somebody who's been affected
by one of these attacks like they don't
necessarily in their immediate family or
maybe they're not their extended family
but someone in their extended family
knows somebody who who was affected and
that's not something that we're really
used to over here you know these are
little pin Pricks on a giant map over
here San Bernardino happens or the Pulse
Nightclub M very small you know drops in
the ocean not so over there no so I
think
that they don't care right now um and
you know if you if you try and see the
perspective from the Israeli side
imagine that your sister or your your
mother or your
daughter was you know you got to see the
social media of her being dragged Away
by her hair after being raped and
Bloated into the back of a truck while
people are yelling Al Akbar and then
executed on camera and then executed on
camera later there's no stopping there's
no stopping there's no stopping
so I I believe that this is going to
be um very
very destructive for Hamas which brings
the question about and I sort of already
alluded to it what is Hamas what were
they thinking of trying to get out of
this now what is it solinsky says that
the the the result or the reaction of
the people that you attack is the actual
that's what you want that's what the
that's the true benefit of like a
gorilla attack is it's not that you you
know blew up a water supply or you
killed killed three civilians it's what
they do back to you that's the reward
that's what you wanted so is that what
we're looking at here Hamas is in a
win-win situation because no matter
almost no matter what Israel
does they're screwed because if Israel
sat back and said you know what we're
we're logical people and we want to
continue to move forward towards peace
well then they're just going to get more
attacks and things are going to get
worse if they go hard in the paint and
start total Destruction they're going to
get the world popular support eventually
turning against them and it seems like
it's a almost a win-win situation for
Hamas I think pending some unforeseen
unforeseen by me outcome I think Hamas
probably already feels like they have
won whatever happens after this you know
you there a lot of them are going to get
killed a huge number of them are going
to get killed but these are people who
in the past have demonstrated a
willingness to put on a suicide vest and
step onto a school bus so so they're not
making the same calculations as you and
me when it comes to them dying right
would you say real quick would you say
so you bring up that that calculation
right there and would you say that when
um the Hamas members go out and shoot
and kill a bunch of women and children
and rape and murder them that their
calculation is off because that's
something that happens more readily in
their culture you know women get raped a
lot in in that culture there's honor
killing of women there's abuse of women
I mean I I've seen it plenty of times
those you know women in those countries
often times they are you know they're
basically slaves sex slaves it's a
terrible situation so so they're
miscalculating like the real effect that
that has on our mentality yeah maybe on
the other hand you know I I named this
episode uh the administration of
savagery after a document jihadist
document that was published back in ' 04
you probably probably were getting
briefed on and familiar with it at the
time so one of the things it talks about
Osama Bin Laden talked about this
jihadists everywhere have talked about
this just like sa Linsky that uh you
know provoking an overwhelming response
is actually the goal and that's why so
many of these attacks because you got to
think about it like Hamas has to know
even if they don't quite know how how
strongly we're going to react against
violence toward women say or something
they still know that you know if they
were to go attack Israeli military bases
which they did and did some damage or
even uh go just go take a bunch of
hostages or something um as opposed to
going into a kibutz and behe beheading
children and raping women and and you
know videotaping this they that's
designed to elicit shock and outrage and
to and to create the kind of mechanical
response that really especially in a
democratic country like Israel it really
is kind of a a mechanical response what
happens next
because you know you can't even if
Netanyahu was just suddenly Gandhi and
he was like you know what uh we're not
going to fall for this trap we see what
they're trying he would get thrown out
of office and replace by somebody who
was going to go punish these people
because the legitimacy of any state and
especially State like Israel that has
dealt with what it's dealt with over the
years and to a certain degree this goes
for Hamas and and you know the
Palestinian Authority and stuff so any
state that you need to be able to
demonstrate a capability to protect your
citizens you can't always protect them
though and you have to uh demonstrate
capability to retaliate when when that
does you know slip through your net and
Israel's always embraced that philosophy
because you can't you know
no no level of police state in Israel
would would have over the years like
prevented a lot of these attacks from
happening there's just no way unless you
assigned an officer to every Arab in the
country and had them walk around with
them or just there's just no way to do
it that's really practical and so they
had to engage in deterrence and let you
know and and and their responses had to
be somewhat unpredictable where you know
the jihadists might have thought this is
what they were going to get but it
turned out that it was a lot worse than
that and that that has happened in the
past where they did miscalculate in that
sense the uh um you know something has
changed in Israeli tactics over the
years it really started to change in the
late 70s when uh the PLO terrorist
tactics started to change toward you
know the PLO started doing the types of
attacks that we're looking at right now
these just Isis style going into a
village at night and just Massacre as
many families as you can before the
security forces get to you and then you
die and that's yay we won that like that
that's something that really started
happening consistently in the mid late
70s and the
Israelis prior to that had always
focused on targeted assassinations
treating this as a police and
intelligence problem like trying to deal
with these things and uh in the late
'70s they started to transition over to
more dealing with this as a military
problem and they started using uh their
special forces but then their regular
forces to retaliate when these things
happen and when you know the immediate
effect of that was the war in
Lebanon uh which was not good for
anybody it wasn't good for Israel it
wasn't good for anybody involved and for
a while they got away from that but you
know netanyahu's really kind of embraced
that that way of doing things now the
thing is I don't know if there is any
other way to deal with Hamas though like
you you know in addition to the fact
that they had that they demonstrated a
capability to coordinate forces that
they had never demonstrated before I am
blown away and heads are going to roll I
have to imagine in the Israeli
intelligence establishment for how this
got by them I mean the level of plan
this had to minimum this took months
minimum this took months you're the
first first several hours they launched
like 2500 to 5,000 depending on who you
listen to of their cassan Rockets these
things are 7even eight feet long you
know five or six inches in diameter
they're not huge but 2500 of them's
freaking huge is there any indicators so
far as to what happened with the Intel
CU yeah you could go down the whole list
of you know again I pointed out in the
beginning thousands of people involved I
point out in the beginning that oh this
didn't take like some excessive amount
of coordination compared to an American
operation but don't get me wrong when
you have like you said 2500 to 5,000
Rockets when you have these little
aircraft being used when you have boats
being used to bring in when you have
tunnels being used we have breaching of
of legitimate security fences like all
those things they absolutely took some
level of coordination and how many
troops were involved thousands of troops
involved you know to give you an example
when we were in Iraq and we would be
doing it an operation with the Iraqi
soldiers we wouldn't tell them what we
were doing until you know a half an hour
prior to and this is we're talking about
30 guys yeah and so why because guys
have been burned by that before so now
you're talking about three four
5,000 over the course of I bet they
could get this thing coordinated under a
month that's my assessment um again I'm
thinking really decentralized command
assuming they had the equipment in place
and yeah that would be the logistics
would be harder than anything else but
also they don't have like a huge
Logistics train who knows I I would have
to get a better look at their Logistics
picture but all that being said let's
say it was a month a month of 5,000
people keeping a secret that's that's
not feasible it's actually not feasible
on the 50th anniversary of the yamkipur
war where you had to imagine that
Israeli intelligence was on alert yeah
um supposedly the Egyptians tried to
warn them
and you know
it's it's tough obviously just like with
9911 like it's you get indications every
single day hey an attack's coming or
whatever and you you have to sift out
what to take seriously and how seriously
to take it but this is a big this was a
it's amazing because I mean this is not
you know Israel has mad has the
reputation that it has for a reason I
mean you read like books on the history
of the mad and Israeli intelligence
operations and their ability to
infiltrate turn people stay on top not
to mention their signals intelligence
which is topnotch and Gaz is completely
saturated with it um they're good I mean
they they have a reputation for a reason
and it's really amazing that this
somehow got by him and I I got to
imagine heads are going to roll I mean
they got they've got an Israeli General
held captive down there in Gaza right
now there's a video of him being like
hauled off in his pajamas it look like
they pulled him out of bed or something
I mean this is not the kind of thing
that so here's here's the question right
is given everything that's already
happened what does what what would
Israel have to accomplish in order to
feel like they could say Okay that was a
sufficient response to what happened and
we can go home or call this off or or
dial it back because eradicating Hamas I
mean that sounds nice in theory but I
mean you know like I said in
2014 just their Fighters that they had
deployed uh their their actual gun toing
Fighters in that war you know they
supposedly had 12 to 15,000 spread out
along the front and you know when you
count people who weren't holding guns
the people who were just supporters the
people who are 14 years old so they're
not quite there yet but like they're
going to be in a couple years like to
root all those people out and just
eradicate Hamas it just seems like it it
would take a level
of Devastation that would be really hard
to sustain over over the length of time
that it would take you know yeah that's
uh they've got to be asking themselves
that question and I mean Netanyahu said
kind of out of the gate correct me if
I'm wrong like we will make sure this
can never happen again and Hamas will be
destroyed he said Hamas will be or
they've said Hamas will be destroyed
right say that yeah so are they ready to
just like I think there's going to be
some Siege Warfare
activities in Gaza like just Siege
Warfare no one gets in no one gets out
and and over time just wear them
down and see if it's interesting you
know you talk about what the amount of
support that the normal Palestinian that
like who's the most peaceloving
Palestinian that's living in Gaza how
many of them are there and one thing
that sucks about the way the world works
is that people that
want
peace
for obvious reasons they're not Fighters
right so when when you've got the
majority of the PO the gangsters win the
gangsters run thing there's a reason why
gangsters run things you go to a prison
who runs the prison it's it's not the
person who's nicest it's the it's the
person that is will will do the most
destruction and damage in a mob what's
the deal with a mob who ends up running
a mob the people that we're willing to
kill to get to the top and step on other
people if you go to uh a place like this
you go inside Gaza well how did they win
the election how did Hamas win the
election was it because they put to put
together the most positive platform sure
certainly there's a lot of people that
believed in what they were doing but
also there's a lot of people that are
like hey look I'm not you know okay
that's what we're dealing with I don't
want to get smashed I want to live my
life so I'm just kind of on board so
whether or not you could put Siege on
Gaza for a long enough time period that
the people that don't support Hamas
actually turn against them I don't even
know if that's a thing it might not even
be a
thing um and so therefore that idea of
Siege what that turns into is just like
total Destruction there's also that dark
Dynamic that you know you just seen over
and over again where you know maybe
maybe on both sides of a conflict um
just 5% of each side are really hardcore
they want to go over there and Massacre
women and children they want to do
whatever it takes to just harm the other
side because of what they've done to us
Etc like that 5% has a way of being able
to drag everybody else down to their
level over time I mean if you look in
well shoot just exactly what you were
just saying actually go back to the
1990s when the Oslo Accords were being
negotiated you had Arafat and Rabin
shaking hands and look I mean they were
on the cusp of having an actual an
actual deal I mean Yas are Arafat and
you know people today yeah arafat's kind
of old news but this guy for decades was
like the arch terrorist in the world
basically hundreds of Israelis killed
like just disaster like of of a of a
human being and here he was you know
negotiating a a settlement and may or
may not have lasted or whatever but the
Israelis were making some concessions
not enough for Hamas though and so what
did Hamas do Hamas wanted to derail the
whole process after years had been years
of work had been put into this process I
mean Rabin was Rabin was a hardcore
Israeli military guy that's why he was
able to make peace like rich like Nixon
going to China kind of thing and so huge
amount of work from the United States
from the Palestinian Authority from from
Israel in negotiating this and keeping
the process going over over the course
of years and Hamas says well we don't
like where this is going because it's
going to you know if we agree to this
then that's essentially saying that
everything else they've stolen from us
that that's you know ratified and so
they got a couple suicide bombers and
went and blew up a couple city buses in
Israel and it was all over that was it
and then on the Israeli side there was
an extremist religious Zionist who
assassinated the Prime Minister Yak rine
for trying to make peace and give away
parts of you know uh what they
considered their heritage heritage lands
and so these are like how many
Israelis are the type of people who
would want to assassinate the prime
prime minister for making a uh a deal
with you know the Palestinians or who
would even cheer for it if it happened
or who would even equivocate about very
very
few how many Palestinians like are
willing to strap on a suicide bus a
suicide bomb and step onto a bus um
probably like not a majority you know um
and yet those people can dictate terms
to everybody else because you know you
could be a pretty moderate person and
then you see videos of people that you
know your second cousin knew from
college getting raped and murdered while
people cheer all around them and you're
not so moderate anymore you know and the
thing about this conflict is that that
kind of thing's been going on for 70
years now 75 years now and everybody has
so many reasons to be pissed off a lot
of them are good reasons you know um
that everybody feels perfectly righteous
in their
hatred and it's
um I'll tell you man like I I do not
envy the uh the position the predicament
that Israeli planners are in right now
because this is a this is a a situation
that I don't really
think you know the there's a longtime
mayor of Jerusalem Teddy Kik and he's
like the most quotable guy ever he's
always got a good quote for every
situation and somebody asked him
reporter asked him one time what he
thought about the Palestinian
problem and he said uh kind of a famous
quote he said problem Palestinian
problem we don't have a problem problems
have Solutions what we have is a
condition and you manage conditions and
it's you know you manage conditions
until they flare up and become acute
problems and acute conditions and that's
kind of where it looks like it is right
now yeah I definitely had some thoughts
uh preparing for this where I just
started started thinking about oil and
water like there's no there's nothing
you can do you can you can put them in
the same glass and shake them up and
they'll be together for a little while
and then they're going to separate and
and that's the way this is going to work
and so yeah I agree with that assessment
and this is going to get it's going to
get like you said the planners what are
the Israeli planners how much how much
destruction are they okay with at what
point do they care about what the what
the world
does do they care about what the world
thinks do they care if they destroy Gaza
and how many more Decades of hate and
frustration does that bring them in the
future does it matter because they're
already hated and and and frustrated
anyways so yeah that's the question
though right I mean like how many of
these people would they have to
kill to actually improve the situation
because I don't know if there's a number
other than all of them you know what I
mean like so let's say they go in there
and they you know 2014 war was
devastating I mean there were just whole
sections of the city that were destroyed
it was chaos it was a just they
destroyed a lot of Gaza 2 200 people
died 10,000 or so were wounded let's say
they go in here and 100,000 people they
kill 300,000 wounded just a massive
unprecedented assault in the context of
this conflict what's that like a 10 of
the what is it is that 20th of the 20th
of population and which is insane to
think about it is insane to think about
and and and it would also not be that
that is not unimaginable it is not
unimaginable at all because they're so
packed in like sardines and everything
else and so but even then okay so they
they do that kind of damage
unprecedented really Unthinkable damage
in the context of this conflict would
that accomplish anything like I don't
know if it would actually accomplish
anything mhm and I don't I don't really
have a good answer to to what Israel
should do I I mean I know what I I told
people like you know I am sometime new
sometimes nuanced to a fault on this
issue because I know the history well
enough to have sympathy for both sides
causes you know whether or not I have
sympathy for the people involved like
Hamas um I understand the legitimate
Grievances and and concerns that both
sides have and sometimes that you know
like when something like this happens
like you you don't want to lose that
completely because then you get caught
up in emotion and that's what's
happening to a lot of people right now
I'm seeing like pretty reasonable
normally pretty reasonable people like
using I
mean genocidal language on Twitter um
but on the other hand like I you know I
do want to address like one of the
things that that it's something that Pro
Palestine people will bring up and I've
been talking to people over the last few
days about this
is what they'll point out is like okay
look
um they'll ask the question from the
standpoint of the Palestinians what are
we supposed to do you tell us what we're
supposed to do because if we do
nothing which there have been periods of
years where we didn't do much at
all settlements keep expanding in the
West Bank um our pop you know our
Villages and everything are getting
broken up and displaced and that whole
area is just gradually becoming a part
of Greater Israel effective and that's
where things are headed Gaza nothing's
improved in Gaza the place is still
under siege Israel still controls what
goes in and out of it whether we can
have construction materials etc etc and
so for many years people said you know
what the Palestinians should do is look
back to the green March in Spanish
Morocco back in the SE in the 75 I think
it was where Spain still own this part
of the Sahara that you know it now
belongs to Morocco Morocco wanted it
back and Spain wasn't just going to give
it back but Morocco kind the Moroccans
realized that you know what I don't
think these Spanish I don't think these
people really have the will to just kill
a bunch of our civilians who were and so
here's what we're going to do and they
called the green March they all just
walked in and they walked right past the
Border guards because it turned out yeah
they weren't going to just gun down a
bunch of civilians just to hold on to
this place and it worked and so people
have said that's what the Palestinian
should do obviously all the people in
Gaza they should just walk up to the
fence and say hey we're you know just
approach it like that and in 2018 they
kind of tried that it
wasn't 100% you know peaceful there were
some people like flying some kites over
the fence trying to start fires that you
know were on fire and stuff but by the
standards CNN used in America in 2020
during the Floyd riots it was mostly
peaceful um and the Israeli soldiers who
were on the fence were given orders to
shoot anybody who came within 300 yards
of the fence and that eventually after a
little while that got lowered to 100
yards and there are videos of them
shooting people there's a video of some
sniper shooting someone in a wheelchair
they shot kids they shot women
um
and the Palestinians will say okay this
is what you guys have been telling us to
do all this time we did it and they
snipers shot like a thousand of us not a
single Israeli casualty killed or
wounded it was no damage on the Israeli
side and over a thousand people on our
side got shot by snipers so not any kind
of indiscriminate bombing or anything
like this is essentially executions you
know and so this is what happened we
tried the green March tactic this is
what happened so now you tell us what
we're supposed to do and my answer to
those people
is it doesn't at this point like when
you do something like Hamas has done
over the last several days now when
you're recording yourselves raping and
beheading women and and killing children
then you're rolling the iron dice I mean
it's all over like that doesn't matter
like all of those historical grievances
the broader context that's all
interesting once this conflict settles
down and people come sit down at a table
and maybe try to negotiate some then all
that's Rel
right now none of that is relevant I
mean this is a situation where Hamas has
has provoked a reaction that cannot be
stopped at this
point
and it is sad for the people who are
there who are going to be affected who
who maybe don't like Kamas and don't
want this conflict and want it all to
end um but and and I and I do kind of
resent a lot of the you know a lot of
the people out there who are trying to
make it seem like it's just you know
100% of the Palestinians are just
laughing and cheering at dead Israeli
kids and therefore we can kind of just
do whatever we want to the whole
population I I I really resent that way
of thinking it's very
dangerous
but it's also kind of inevitable after
you see things like you've seen over the
last several days you yeah the I mean
what happened in Morocco and Spain
leaving and it's the same thing with
Algeria right the French were like you
know what we're not sticking this thing
out they didn't have the will right it's
a test of Wills the big difference here
being that this is where the Israelis
live like the the Spanish don't need to
stay in in in Morocco and the French
didn't need to stay in Algeria the other
thing that's been interesting and I saw
a little bit right as this happened
right in the
beginning I saw it seemed like media
some people I think probably with good
intent tried to frame the
situation as Israel versus Hamas and I
was like okay they can try and frame it
like that as opposed to being oh this is
Israel against the Palestinians right
they were trying to trying to sus out
this group and say hey this is just
Hamas that is doing this this isn't this
isn't Palestinian palestin Palestinians
at large and that seemed like I I saw
that narrative a little
bit and boy did it kind of fade very
quickly like it faded very quickly I
don't know did you notice that I did and
you know and I can deplore that uh and
be and be sad about it but again
um it's human nature you know when when
you
see a bunch of Palestinian civilians in
Gaza who are gathered around as you're
parading these bodies and they're
cheering like a great Victory and it's
some woman's
body you know may maybe it's you look at
the video and maybe there's a hundred
people there and there's two million
people in Gaza so you know what can you
really conclusion can you draw from that
maybe the only hundred people in the
whole neighborhood who were really
excited about that came out but it it
doesn't matter I mean I you know from
our standpoint I know how I get you know
when I see even in 2004 and these were
soldiers these the Blackwater guys you
know these but when when I see Americans
being paraded
around uh you sort of just you know you
start to go blind a little bit and the
Israelis you know one of the things that
I I think a lot of people don't and I'm
about to put out a a podcast about this
actually this week
um that people don't quite understand
that like they think that what happened
here is like an escalation and it is in
terms of scale but people whose side
from Hamas like that this has somehow
brought things up to another level and
that that is true from the standpoint of
like the scale of the attack but there's
a lot of people I think who who see you
know them them beheading people and
doing all all these horrible things to
civilians women and they think that the
the brutality the level of brutality has
been stepped up and that is not true
Israel has been dealing with this for
decades I mean I put a couple anecdotes
in here I'll go ahead and read one uh
this is from
1978 this is a famous attack in in fact
I'll do this one instead 197 so another
one in 1978 there were dozens of these
attacks over the years I mean hundreds
honestly of these kinds of attacks that
I'm about to read this is a passage from
Rise and kill first by Ronan
Bergman on April 12th 1979 at close to
midnight a Terror Squad from the PLO
Affiliated group headed by Abu abas
landed in a rubber dinghy on the beach
at naharia an Israeli city 7even miles
south of the Lebanese border one of its
four members was Samir countar then 16
and2 years old
after trying to break into a house and
being frightened Away by gunfire and
after killing a policeman who tried to
arrest them the four broke into the
apartment of the Haron family and took
the father Dany and his daughter in not
four as hostages they dragged them to
the beach where soldiers and police had
already deployed and a firefight ensued
countar shot Dany and then grabbed I not
by the hair and dashed her head with all
his might against a rock again and again
until she was dead Danny's wife
smadar hid in a crawl space in their
apartment with their two-year-old
daughter yel smadar covered the
toddler's mouth with her hand to keep
her from crying out and allowing the
attackers to find
them I knew that if y cried out the
terrorist would toss a grenade into the
crawl space and we would be killed she
wrote in an article so I kept my hand
over her mouth hoping she could breathe
as I lay there I remembered my mother
telling me how she had hidden from the
nazzis during the Holocaust this is just
like what happened to my mother I
thought in her Panic smadar pressed too
hard she smothered her little girl the
head of idf's Northern command Major
General avigor yanosh
Bal arrived at the scene shortly after
the incident he saw inette in not's
shattered head yael's lifeless body and
smadar screaming with anguish after
realizing she had lost everything dear
to her you cannot imagine the dimensions
of the atrocity Bengal said at the
funeral for Dany and his two children
prime minister beging quoted a line from
Israel's National poet Haim nman balik
Satan has not yet created Vengeance
sufficient for the blood of a little
child
so you know there are people out there
people in Congress who will say okay
yeah well what about the dead
Palestinian children and in a in a
another context I hear that like if I'm
somebody
you know if I had a kid who was beheaded
or blown to bits by an air
strike um those are going to be roughly
equivalent in the way that I feel about
those things like if that's my
child but there's a huge people who
pretend not to know the difference
between those two things I I don't I
just don't believe the anybody doesn't
understand the difference you know and
the difference is this
is if there's an Air Force Commander who
has ordered air strikes that have killed
civilians um maybe that guy should get
brought up on war crimes maybe all of
these sort of broader moral on a broader
moral level you can condemn him or or
whatever but that guy could be your
neighbor and be fine like you wouldn't
mind having that guy as a neighbor he um
was doing his job in a context that is
is sort of just generally acceptable
whether or not it's right and he could
be a good neighbor a good family man a
good Community member and all those
things if the person next to you went
into that Village and beheaded a bunch
of people and raped a bunch of women or
you know all the things that are going
on you don't want that person as a
neighbor you don't want that person in
your city you don't want that person to
be alive they they they shouldn't be
alive you know these are there's there's
no prison deep you know there's no deep
enough hole to put that person in that
we would ever feel really comfortable
that that person should stick around so
it is totally different I mean the level
of savagery you engage in especially
when like with Isis like with uh Hamas
during this attack when the savagery and
the shock of it is the
point that's school shooter stuff you
know
and it's evil I mean it's really evil
and you can make all the historical
arguments you want about Zion
colonization and you know the
settlements on the West Bank and you
know how all those things and that's all
fine but at the end of the day when a
bunch of your young men go across the
border and rape and kill a bunch of
women and children and then then you
know you're not going to find a big
audience and the audience you find
you're certainly not going to find me in
it why is it then do you think that
narrative gets so uh drowned out at such
a massive scale because it seems real
obvious um that that no one would be
saying yeah but to women getting
kidnapped raped and murdered children
getting executed raped and executed
raped and kidnapped and executed it
doesn't seem like there would be a uh
any qualifiers for any of those and yet
it's there it's there it's there loud I
mean we saw we saw protests around the
world from
Australia
to Michigan of people out
supporting what's happening and how does
that how does that happen I believe
something it has something to do with
the fact that um you know when you watch
Star
Wars the good guy is the rebels right we
we we we support the underdog and the
world there's a reason that that movie
and that that thing resonates around the
world it's David versus Goliath even
biblical it's like oh the little guy
versus the big guy so is that the
narrative that just carries this whole
story through is that oh there's people
that have been oppressed I've been
oppressed and so I support the people
that have been oppressed no one there's
no move movement of oppressors right
there's no one that says hey you know
join my club I'm one of the oppressors
you know I should start one of those
yeah but but but that's that's truth
right there is no Club of people that
says we're the oppressors we you know
come you can join my who have you
oppressed if you haven't oppressed
anybody significantly enough you can't
join my club there's no there's nothing
like that
um I mean nobody but straight up
criminal gangs uh really looks at
themselves as oppressors Hamas doesn't
look at themselves that way you know the
national socialists in Germany this is a
crazy thing that you know I I warn
people about getting caught up in war
fever when you start catching
yourself you
know it's sad when civilians and kids
get killed period And if you find
yourself getting sort of inerd to that
you know you do need to step take a step
back because here's the thing the
Germans thought that they were doing
what they had to do to protect Germany
and the German people they really
believed in the righteousness of their
own cause they weren't just over there
rubbing their hands like M like Dr claw
they thought that they were doing what
had to be done and everybody pretty much
believes that except for again like just
straight up criminal gangs who are
extorting and exploiting people that way
and it's because you know we can you can
talk yourself in anything you can find
reasons I mean Hamas
has again like from a historical
standpoint go listen to my my whole
series on the early Zionist movement and
the creation of Israel they have
historical grievances that anybody who I
think uh is is fair-minded would say
deserve a hearing you know um and so
they can take that and convince
themselves over time that killing
children from the other side is is
actually accept cable or even even
laudable um first of all war fever you
talked about war fever and we have a
saying in the SEAL Teams everybody wants
to be a frog man on a sunny day meaning
when you're down in Coronado and you're
like a a tourist on the beach and you
see these young seals studs that are out
there on then to run and it's is Friday
afternoon and it's nice and warm and
looks like the best job in the world of
course everyone was oh I want to be a
seal but they don't want to actually do
seal which is cold wet miserable
dangerous and you kill and you die well
there's like a heavier version of that
and it's what that war fever is like
everybody you know around the world is
cheering on their
side and these are just like the cries
of uh you know big mouths because you
know when when it when it comes time
to put on some kit
and go do
work that that that those mouths get a
lot
quieter um so there's that going on
there's that going on a lot uh the other
thing is you know I I just re-released a
book called leadership strategy and
tactics I had a new Expanded Edition and
one of the big things I talk about it is
decision-making and I I go through this
one of the one of the new things I added
to the book was about decision- making
and there's a process that I'd go
through for decision- making and it's
like how much time do I have I look at
the four laws of combat leadership it
cover Move simple prioritize and execute
decentralized command then I've got some
checks in there that
are they they take like an an
introspective thought process number one
is my ego making this
decision because you can make some
really bad decisions based on your ego
is are my emotions making this decision
because you can make some really bad
decisions based on your emotions do I
understand the perspective of other
people the other people that I work with
do I understand their perspective
because if I don't understand their
perspective if I don't understand my my
enemies perspective if I don't
understand my you know counterparty if
I'm in a negotiation if I don't
understand their perspective if I don't
understand my subordinates perspective
if I'm a leadership position if I don't
understand my boss's perspective if I'm
in a leadership position but I'm working
for someone else if I don't understand
what my peers are thinking if I don't
see a lot of perspective I'm not making
good decisions and then there's this
point about is my decision
in support of what we are
doing tactically and
strategically because if it
doesn't then I shouldn't be doing it so
when you look at like this
decision-making process we we we already
talked about Hamas like what is hamas's
strategic goal did they increase their
chance like if you a normal Palestinian
person and you're like you know what I'd
really like I really wish we could have
a a two-party State I wish we could have
a little chunk of land and I wish
everything was cool we could kind of
like live live ourselves be you know
have our own little part of the world
and I'd be really stoked okay cool in
what way shape or form did Hamas just
forward that Concept in any in any way
yeah you know Hamas are absolutist in
their aims they're not looking to
compromise um they you know Arafat said
one time this is an exact quote but it
was it's pretty close that Israel will
be defeated by the womb the Palestinian
mother
and that you can kill us you can mow the
lawn all you want but we're going to
have two babies for every one person you
kill and we're going to catch up to you
one of these days and from the
perspective of group like Hamas you know
they obviously they're not trying to
conquer Israel with an attack like
this I think what they're trying to do
to a degree is you know they have their
own domestic and and even International
like goals probably derailing the peace
process with the Arab states between you
know Israel and Saudi Arabia and so
forth as well as just showing their own
people that we have the power to strike
and and cause damage and the Zionist
machine fears us or whatever they have
those type of things but as far as what
they're actually trying to accomplish
with regard to Israel is they're not
trying to conquer the place they're just
trying to make New York City or London a
more attractive place for Jews to live
than Tel Aviv that's the goal you know
there if because you you might be an
Israeli Jew who's you know Patriot and
all those things but you love your
daughter you love your daughter and you
have cousins in New York a whole bunch
of people he's got a job waiting for you
and everything and people do this Israel
has seen over recent years you've seen
an influx of people coming in from
Europe because of the islamist
anti-Semitism that's cropped up there
but before but before that there was an
outflow of people people were leaving
Israel Moving to the United States and
other places I know Israelis who who've
done that and um you know like we said
Israel is a small country it's got a
small Jewish population and I think I
think it's 25 or 30% of the population
already is Arab and a lot of those are
moderate Arabs who are certainly no fans
of Hamas or anything like that but
pretty much all of
them a vast majority of them put it that
way are in support of the Palestinian
cause in general terms and so if it's
30% now and the Arabs are having more
babies than the Jews and you can create
enough chaos just make the place
unlivable create enough chaos that
people who value the life of their
daughter more than they do their
commitment to the Zionist cause say you
know what I'm gonna take that job my
cousin has for me in New York my
family's leaving enough is enough leave
this problem to other people who don't
have kids or something like that that if
that starts to happen and now it's
33% Arab compared to 67% Jewish and then
now it's 38% and you start to get
Israelis looking around and you know
looking down the road and seeing charts
that say in you know
2052 it's going to be 51% Arab or it's
goingon to you know things are going in
that
direction then that outflow could
accelerate because people don't want to
be the last one fighting to get out the
door and I think that's part of the goal
just create enough chaos make this play
and that's that's it partially answers
why the savagery you know part of it I
do think is to provoke a massive
response that they can use for
propaganda purposes and to delegitimize
the Arab regimes that try to make peace
with
Israel um but part of it I think is
they're they're trying to shock and
terrify people into leaving and um that
sounds implausible like nobody would
ever do that but it it like I said to a
degree it was happening in small numbers
and it's not implausible especially when
you look at the demographic direction of
that region in general but that country
specifically uh
anyway
and you know Hamas is again these people
aren't thinking in terms of individual
lifespans these are people who are
perfectly willing to die even eager to
die you know people have to remember
sometimes
that these these these people in Hamas
these young men who go join Hamas and
just the people in God and General like
they grow up from the earliest
age just in a stew of hate propaganda
that would make you know the most
anti-Semitic person in the United States
skin crawl that is what they hear every
day it's what they hear from adults
authority figures the most prestigious
people in Hamas rather in Gaza the most
prestigious people are Martyrs which
often means people who went and killed a
bunch of civilians before they got shot
by Israeli you know police and there
have been you know a lot of examples
where they've pulled school children in
Gaza and asking them what do you want to
be when you grow up and something like
65 70 depending on the poll percent say
I want to be a martyr because that's
everybody wants to be high status in the
context of your society and that's what
high status is there you know
and how you deal with something like
that is uh I mean that's a next level
problem it really is it's not a typical
counterinsurgency problem no no it's a
it's
it's it's
beyond it's beyond I don't know what the
solution is um I I when you think about
it in these terms though and you're
Israel you have got to take dramatic
actions there's no choice like there's
you got to take dramatic actions and
you've got to kind of shrug your
shoulders and say you know we're we're
doing this I mean because otherwise
Hamas will get exactly what I was just
talking about you know if if the state
does not if something like this happens
and the state cannot demonstrate the
will to act decisively then you are
going to start getting Israelis who care
about the safety their daughters saying
you know what I don't know about this so
they have to they have no choice yeah
that
and as that
escalates this is the real another real
concern here is
as Israel executes on this which again
do they have a choice you know from an
emotional level we're not supposed to
make decisions emotionally but when
someone that you know some someone
within your
circle of people that you know people
that you care about
was
raped tortured kidnapped and executed
from an emot the all of a sudden those
decisions start becoming very emotional
then you start looking at it from a
logical perspective of okay if we don't
do
anything we no longer can protect our
citizenry and our citizenry begins to
leave and we will not have this State
anymore so they are going to have to
respond in a
very heavy way when they do that look
it's it was within one day there was
people around the world in support of
Palestine or the Palestinians what how
does this this is what worries me about
this is we start to get you know it's
like when they when they detonated the
first atom bomb they thought there was
there was a couple theories that when
that one hydrogen split and hit the next
one that one would hit the next one and
that one hit the the next one it would
destroy the entire world this is to me a
similar situation where Israel is about
to unleash well as they said hell said
you guys wanted hell you're going to get
it they're about to unleash hell what
what is going to happen around the world
with terrorist attacks there's there's
Palestinian people around the world that
are strongly in support of
Hamas what is going to happen when they
start to act out does this thing
escalate what is what is Hezbollah going
to do are they going to open up a second
front to the north where do you think
this escalates
to it's hard to say um there are a lot
of factors involved but I'll tell you
the thing I worry about
is I think that the war in
Ukraine has had the effect of telling
these regimes like Iran you know some of
these regimes I'll call them Rogue
regimes in the sense of being Rogue from
the us-led International System the one
that we are typically at odds with um
it's kind of shown them or at least
given them the idea and this might be
wrong but that's what you were talking
about the very beginning about how Wars
happen when people miscalculate the will
or strength the other side that
technological changes you know whether
it's drones and all these different
things that these superpowers aren't
quite so super anymore that maybe like
you know we might be a little bit ragtag
compared to them but if you exploit
different advantages like you know Iran
might be thinking like go ahead and try
and invade us you know the the base in
Kuwait is within range of all our
missiles the uh Embassy in baghdad's
within range of all our missiles we've
got you know maybe that would that would
there's already a Shiite government that
is semi- aligned with Iran in Iraq maybe
that would lead to an extremist Shiite
government that's fully aligned with
Iran taking over in Iraq and they might
just be getting bold like that and if
that's the case you know especially
since these you know the the the syrians
Hezbollah the
Iranians you got to remember they've
been in combat recently they were in
hard hard combat against Isis and um
al-nusra and the other you know the
other jihadists in Syria for several
years I mean I I think I read somewhere
Hezbollah took 5 to 8,000 dead which is
a massive amount I mean that's that's
conventional for level of casualties
that they're taking and um so they've
got experience they've they've you know
they're not going to have a fear of of
warfare and combat they may have
overconfidence in their air defense
capabilities you know Hezbollah
specifically but but Iran and and Syria
as well and it it may lead to some
miscalculations and they may just look
at you know what happened in Afghanistan
they may look at our president who you
know can hardly Mumble out a complete
sentence without being carted off by his
handlers and they may just look at this
and say this is a good opportunity for
us to accomplish some things we've been
talking about for a long time because
you know nobody is minding the store
right now and that might not be true you
know that might it might be that they
try to do something like that and next
year we say oh okay this is serious now
and things change and we elect somebody
that's different and things do shape up
really quick and that's a terrible move
move for them but you know these might
be the calculations that they're making
and so um how it escalates I mean I
really hope Hezbollah does not get
involved if
Hezbollah opens a second front and and
it really is not just harassment but
opens a front in the north then Israel
is going to go into full existential
mode and it's going to be fighting as if
its existence depends on it because it
does you know Hezbollah last I saw is
the thought to have 60 to 80,000
Fighters dedicated Fighters like that's
not the IDF but that's serious you know
and um if that happens then Israel's
probably going to attack Syria they're
gonna attack Lebanon Iran might get
involved it could spiral very very
quickly and
um I I I think hezbollah's incentivized
to not do that but I don't know this
might be you know there might be a lar
what's the incentivization for them to
not that get in the game that hezbo has
worked really hard over the years to um
to to play for to to to try to take the
road of them you know them being
representative of Lebanon as a as a
country and so they actually have some
support from the Drews and Shiite and
even the Christian Community there not
like all these people are you know push
Israel into the sea people but they see
Hezbollah as like Defenders of Lebanon
and they don't hate them them at least
and they even have like some some
positive support but if they go pick a
fight with
Israel because the gazin you know that
Hamas decided to go Massacre a bunch of
women and children and and partygoers
and so Hezbollah decides they're going
to go get involved and now all these
Christians and Drews and Sunni and
Shiite civilians are getting their homes
bombed or their neighborhoods destroyed
or or uh by Israel um that that might
that very possibly and probably would
come back on Hezbollah now the question
is and you kind of been talking about
this the whole time is you know let's
revisit that in a couple weeks after
Israel is bouncing Rubble in Gaza for a
while and reports are coming out about
how people don't have water and you know
children who are wounded uh can't be
treated in hospitals because they don't
have supplies for them and this starts
to happen then maybe in some of these
Arab countries maybe in Lebanon you
start to see people starting to Bay for
some Israeli blood and maybe Hezbollah
would have the cover to do something
like that um I mean at a certain point a
group like Hezbollah you have to it has
to answer the question to its own people
um what is it what do you exist for if
not this like what is it that we need
you and not just the Lebanese Army or
whatever for um if not to eventually do
something and I think that's you know
that's part of what motivates a group
like Hamas to do something like this
it's like what do what do you exist for
if not to you know at the very least
fight back against the occupier or
whatever and they have to demonstrate
some some willingness and capability to
do that and
Hezbollah you know granted they I mean
again they they have been in combat
recently and I think everybody in
Lebanon knows that that they did uh you
know good service for the people of
Lebanon put it that way because they
were fighting legitimate jihadis out
there um but it would like like I said
if if if they do open a second front up
in the north man Israel the way people
that I would talk to when I would go
over there would talk about Hezbollah I
wouldn't say they're champing at the bit
to get that one back but they all had
the mentality that the next time we get
into a real fight with Hezbollah that it
is on like Donkey Kong and like and the
and it's a fight to the Finish
and so hopefully it doesn't go to that
hopefully you know it stays confined
like it did in 2014 that the assault in
2014 was bad I mean they destroyed again
whole swas of the city in Gaza it was
really bad and Hezbollah didn't get
involved and Iran didn't get involved
and so hopefully that's where it
stays um but if Israel is really
dedicated to going in and trying to root
out and eradicate
Hamas then that gives that that opens up
a large amount of time for the
environment to change how much influence
does America have over what they're
going to do and not
do I think a lot you know um well the
question is how much influence do we
have right now you know by the end of
the Obama
Administration he like there was like
reports from people who were in the
administration who would say that they
couldn't get the Saudis or the Israelis
to pick up the phone literally they
could not get them to pick up the phone
they just alienated them so much and
when you look at you know Israel whether
you think they're overplaying the
Iranian threat or whatever it is they
are they don't think they're overplaying
it they are very concerned about the
Iranian nuclear program and all these
things it's not just a thing they're
doing to you know to to Jin up
right-wing votes for Netanyahu or
something they believe that this is a
very serious threat Biden just gave them
six or seven billion
dollars these con constantly like just
tried to shift away from you know there
there there there are These two factions
in Washington DC and I'm talking to a
few people about this because I don't
fully understand it I see I've seen only
the outlines of it when you look at who
funds which think tanks and you know
various things but that there's a
faction in DC and the Obama
Administration was squarely in this camp
where they were very
proter and
pro-iran and they really didn't like I
mean truly like you you've got the Ben
rhods the sort of foreign policy Guru of
the Obama Administration who's going on
Twitter this isn't recently but this is
in in recent years going on Twitter and
just calling Muhammad bin Salon in Saudi
Arabia calling him a murderous Thug and
all these I mean this is an ally whether
or not you know calling uh calling
Netanyahu a racist and a fascist and
stuff I mean this is
whether or not you think that um you
know you're a US foreign policy adviser
to the president and these are our
allies and that's extreme language to be
putting out into the public sphere like
that and but he was doing it and a lot
of those people have done it and they
really don't like Saudi Arabia they
don't like Israel they don't like the
sort of the security network that we
have spent decades kind of constructing
over there with Egypt and Israel and
Saudi Arabia and the UAE and Oman and
Jordan and turkey obviously has been a
little bit of a loose cannon over the
last decade and a half but they they
they just don't like that they think
that this whole this whole thing where
we take one side of this Sunni Shiite
fight and you know we say if these
people don't like Iran then we don't
like Iran either we're just going to
back our guys you know um that the Obama
Administration wanted to abandon that he
he wanted to try to make friends with
Iran
and you know he was doing it over the
screaming protests of the Israelis and
the Saudis who you know that he wouldn't
even allow them to be involved in the
negotiations and it really alienated
them and so who knows what's going to be
what it's going to be like with the
Biden Administration I mean Trump you
know that's one of the this was like one
of the main themes of the Trump
presidency is he was very much 100% on
board with that traditional security
architecture the Israelis the Saudis UAE
build them up support them and if Iran
wants to be their enemy then Iran is our
enemy and the theory behind that was if
we do that then we
can you know pull back maybe not leave
but we can pull back because now there's
like a balance of power yeah if Saudi
and UAE and Jordan and Israel and Egypt
are all on friendly terms they can
handle their business in the Middle East
and we can kind of pull back a little
bit and uh you know there are other
factions there's there's that the Kotter
Iranian faction that um you know the
Brookings Institute gets a ton of
funding from Cotter a lot of a lot of
the think tanks do and you look at the
people who go into government and then
get out and go get a cure at one of
these uh at one of these think tanks and
then you look at the policies they
supported and support when they go into
government and it all tracks you know
and so there's a lot of that stuff going
on that um is sort of the deep politics
of all this it's it's hard to decipher
though as this unfolds as Israel rolls
into Gaza which hasn't started yet but
we are both assuming that they're going
to roll in there and cause mass
destruction and now you're going to get
like uae's been obviously they they they
were in League basically with Israel um
that was under Trump kind of sign that
agreement um Jord always been kind of
there what what's going to happen with
the populace inside I mean I saw uh
again a video of protesters in Jordan
fullon Palestinian Flags
everywhere like what there's going to be
some
destabilization as Israel starts
to attack and Destroy Gaza there's going
to be some massive
destabilization in the Islamic world I
think
think to a degree we've actually never
seen before that's why the longer this
goes
on like Israel is on a timeline here
because the thing is like they might not
care what people think they have to go
do what they have to do maybe they don't
care what some left-wing group in France
thinks or something as they protest you
can kiss my ass but what they do care
about is like they really do want to
make peace with Saudi Arabia and Jan all
these countries I mean this is is that
would
be uh I
mean it would be just they really want
that put it that way like the people
over there really want that it matters
to them and they understand that
Israelis are very practical in their
politics like they have to be they've
always had to be very practical in their
politics and they understand the
position that some of these regimes are
in that they are sitting on top of
volcanoes you know populations like
Saudi Arabia is a perfect example people
think of the Saudi royal family as this
just extremist wahhabist and there are
members of the royal family who
certainly like that but I talked to a
Saudi one time he didn't live in Saudi
Arabia anymore he'd come to the US but
he's pretty just liberal he's a Muslim
but he was pretty liberal just uh normal
guy and he was full on in support of the
royal family and I was like huh that's
interesting what about you know whatever
women driving and da d da and he was
like you don't understand if we in
instituted democracy in Saudi Arabia the
next day we would elect a government
that was way more extreme than the royal
family the royal family is a moderating
force and I was like huh that's
interesting certainly the case in Jordan
uh certainly the case in in Egypt you
know where in Jordan in Egypt just you
know there there are Cosmopolitan people
who are not uh extremists or anything
but there's large very I mean look what
happened in Egypt during the Arab Spring
the Muslim Brotherhood might not be the
majority of the population but they were
able to elect the
president you know
and I mean Hamas is the the Palestinian
branch of the Muslim Brotherhood that's
what Hamas is and so you know Israel is
looking at that and they're not going to
completely ignore the predicament that
these Arab regimes are in because they
do want to normalize relations with them
on the other
hand you know they are in a position
it's like you said they have no choice
but to retaliate massively and to try to
do something that
that that looks like a sufficient
response for what just happened
and then it's going to take a lot you
know all right well the the interest or
the the what I think is a dynamic that's
very different here as well is this is
going to be like a
daytoday
changing there this is going to this is
going to be a dynamic this is a more
Dynamic situation than normal conflict
because of all the explosiveness in the
in the region of all the things that can
go wrong of all the parties that are in
play of all the the I mean just the
proximity of everything right the
proximity like oh you know we we go to
war with Afghanistan it's it takes a
long time to get all that set up or Iraq
it takes a long time for those things
take time this is now and every change
on the battlefield is going to impact
strategically what's going on with all
the partners that are in play we're
going to have to pay attention to this
and pay attention close um yeah we we we
should revisit this in a few weeks as
things develop because it will be
interesting to see if uh if it does
follow that familiar pattern from 06 in
2014 where that initial surge of
Sympathy for the Israeli side after a
few weeks of images coming out of Gaza
of you know babies crying and and Rubble
on the streets um that you know if
previous patter holds that's going to
start to change and the media narrative
and everything is going to be very
different and so it'll be interesting to
see how it plays out yeah it's going to
be interesting to see how all these
different players act and
react um we'll try and get to you all a
little
sooner but uh if you want to check us
out yeah check out uh Daryl's podcast
called martyr made this is the the he's
got the best podcast about the Israeli
Palestinian conflict what is it the
first six right it's the first six of
that series it's as in-depth as you
could ever want it he gets as much hate
mail from Palestinians as he does from
Israelis he gets as much love mail from
Israelis as he does Palestinians the
thing about Daryl you got to remember is
his arguments take a they have a long
Arc to them so as he tries to explain
things he deviates and leaves and it
takes him a long time to get to his
point because he wants to be
well-rounded unless you follow him on
Twitter in which case he's a troll and
uh you just got
to understand that don't do that yeah
don't do that uh but but do check out
martyr maid he's got a bunch of other
series on there as well but there's no
better time to listen to the uh martyr
made podcast the first six series about
the Israeli Palestinian conflict um I
obviously have a couple other podcasts
Joo podcasts Joo underground.com you can
support that we sell stuff at Joost
store.com have origin usa.com joof
fuel.com also Daryl has his substack
it's martyr made. substack
docomo company because all problems
including this problem is a leadership
problem and that's at Echelon front.com
that's it for now everybody and thanks
for listening as things
certainly
unravel this is darl and Joo out